hi i'm michael cimino and i played
victor and who's original series
love victor hello my name is bibi and i
play
lake i'm anthony trappell and i play
felix
hi my name is isabella ferreira and i
play flora salazar and love victor hello
i'm george c i play benji hello i'm
rachel hilson
and i play mia what's your name oh i got
excited
my name is mason gooding and i play
andrew spencer
on hulu's love victor and today we're
playing
who's who with buzzfeed
who's most like their love victor
character
one am i anthony
he's cr he's got quirks similar to felix
if you were not as creative
compassionate and truthful to who you
are the way mia is anthony turpell would
have been my answer for felix but that's
not the case you
i did when i last last year when i took
the like
who's where you most like i got me so i
guess that makes sense
you me all right i knew you were gonna
do that we're both an
animated bunch you know felix animated
bunch
we i like to use hand gestures felix is
also in the hand gesture
she's she's testicular exactly and we're
both dorks
i think who springs out to my mind is uh
anthony i think he's most like
his character they're both interested in
really like obscure things
and it's very endearing this is easy for
me i'm gonna say
anthony trappell he's most like felix
they're both just super goofy and like
always have random facts for some reason
to be honest i'd probably say
anthony trappell is the most like felix
he's always
being goofy and doing funny silly stuff
kind of like felix does
who's the least like their love victor
character
bella is probably the least like her
character she is like such a sweetheart
and like
super kind and thoughtful me i'm gonna
say me
actually i'm not as mean or just like
you know feisty as she is
mason yeah okay he's the sweetest person
in the world
mason is a sweetie you
um and also maybe bella pilar
i was not nearly as cool as andrew was
in high school
so we differ in that respect i guess
though george is not
american so there's that too he's not
american he also
dresses better than benji if you can
believe it benji's got my favorite
outfits but george still has
more drip than benji if you can believe
it thank you mason i've wanted to steal
some of benji's wardrobe so
i'll definitely take inspiration from
his anyway i'm tempted to say michael
for this one i think
victor is a much better basketball
player than michael is in real life all
right george listen
i didn't know we were talking about the
smack it's cool i just i just know where
we're at now
who's most likely to get on stage and be
amazing at karaoke oh bb baby would
probably be the best at karaoke she's so
good she's such a great singer
you fella well we have a lot of singers
you would be fantastic well thank you
the problem is i just answered who i
would want to hear
sing i think bella has a beautiful voice
but she would never because she
is so shy about it yeah if i had her
voice
i would be singing constantly for sure
phoebe
100 she has the voice of an angel
i always enjoy singing but i am super
shy i have
stage fright um surprisingly so i don't
think that would be me at all
bibi she's probably the most ready i was
out with michael there was a guitar
going around
he launched into a daniel caesar song so
uh you know he might also be a good cam
today
everybody you could okay bb would be the
first
to hop on karaoke and kill it you would
go after because you'd see it would be
fun and you would sing a song and it
would be better than everyone was
expecting
then i think michael would go because
he's secretly been waiting to be asked
to do karaoke so he could do those
little trill things
once everyone was like settle down and
not pick maybe they're trying to talk
bella would hop up and just blow
everyone away that would be karaoke in a
nutshell with what victor
who's the best at doing impressions of
other cast members
i'm gonna say mason because i feel like
he's just the only one that's ever
like done impressions of us i would say
mason is probably the best at doing
impressions of the other cast members
especially myself george george
yep george is so scarily
good at impressions it's ridiculous he
does this impression of me that kills me
i say what's the crack a couple of my
best friends are irish
and it's an irish phrase and you just
say what's a crack what's up
george does this impression in his
american accent where he goes around and
he goes what's the crack
when he does the lean in for you for the
the handshake
iconic anthony has this like handshake
that you just can't miss you know it's a
full lean in he goes
hey there how are you you know and it's
yeah right in your face and
and george does it so well i feel like
i've got this one in the back
bb's she's always like what's the crack
i'm happy to throw out a michael
impression he's always like all right
bet
yeah sure oh yeah i got you bro i think
george is good at doing michael
i'm gonna i think i'm good at doing you
can we see somebody's
if you think you could do a good me i'd
like to see a good meeting all right
everybody uh so um
gather round um this is our new team
member victor
am i doing mason or andrew
that's so that would be my impression of
you
rachel's the only person i've ever met
that actually giggles by saying
who's the best at giving relationship
advice i think i do
but that's cool i think yeah if you
think you're
yeah you're you're good um
rachel i was gonna say mason okay good
at it too
his vocabulary off the chart vocabulary
any
problem you have and you go up to him he
will give a monologue in a good in a
good way
rachel as well though this is true i go
to rachel sometimes when i'm just
having a moment she can say the simplest
thing that is like
the most profound thing rachel's amazing
i'm gonna give this one to her
i think then again he's just good at
giving advice in general he's he's just
the person that i feel like everyone
goes to talk to
mason's really good at giving
relationship advice maybe not
necessarily about like romantic
relationships because uh
i'm single he's always good to like get
advice from and stuff like that
who's most likely to accidentally like
an old picture of their crush's
instagram
i'm gonna say michael i feel like that's
a me thing because i'm just
really not the best at this kind of
stuff it would definitely be me
michael oh or yeah but
yeah i'm not good at social media i
really don't know what's happening most
of the time
and so i feel like i've definitely
accidentally double tapped
i think i'm gonna have to give this one
to anthony again because
i feel like he's the least techie out of
all of us rachel hilsen
if that's the case it's only because i
am
the grandmother of the cast and so i'm
not as
savvy who's most likely to be caught
taking a selfie
i think bella's a fan of the selfie
isn't she bella anthony k
anthony i've just seen anthony k take
many a selfie but
bella has some killer selfies on
instagram isabella ferreira
thank god honestly thank you lord for
her selfies like
we stand i would either say bella or
myself
because i do be using snapchat a lot and
so does bella
yeah probably me who's most likely to
pull prank on set
michael michael oh my god cool michael
or
anthony chapel michael definitely takes
that one that would be me
i definitely scared way more people than
anybody else
who's most likely to introduce you to a
band musician you've never heard of
i'm gonna have to give this one to baby
because she has introduced me to some
pretty amazing music
rachel you you 100 rachel rachel has
like a
stellar music taste and every time
i'm in her car i'm just like constantly
shazaming
whatever is on i'm going to say anthony
trapel because he always has like a like
a really weird
band or something that he actually puts
me on to i'm just gonna have to go with
george even though
bb does have phenomenal music taste
george has introduced me to so many
different like
like low-key bands i didn't hear of but
i think bb
is a close second for sure for sure bibi
and george
i was gonna say bibi and bella george is
definitely an old soul and so his music
taste reflects that i didn't know who
phoebe
phoebe bridgers was bella put me on i
was like yeah she's pretty good
who's most likely to laugh during an
awkward situation
i feel like michael's got a bit of a
giggle he can kind of laugh his way
through
through any awkward situation i think i
would probably be that person that would
laugh during an awkward situation i'm
just kind of awkward sometimes
yeah i don't mean to
it just comes out rachel i think but i i
could also say me as well i get i
i laugh at everything though really
which is hilarious because you get these
moments where something awkward
happens and it's quiet and she would go
who's most likely to spontaneously get a
tattoo on a night out
michael and mason one hundred percent
mike mason
but they're both working that's actually
good in tattoos i'm gonna have to give
this one to michael because
every time i see that man he has a new
tattoo um
it's only amazing getting mason
gooding's the only answer to this
question
this has got to go to mason not me i do
have tattoos but i don't have as many as
mason has way more tattoos than i do
i think it's just because i talk about
my tattoos way more and i got
like in a big place here so let it be
known
even though i do have tattoos mason has
the most tattoos
who's most likely to throw the best
house party
yeah i would say you and michael both
work in that scenario but you've grown
really good
different vibes yours is more chill
michael's
is more everyone's gonna rock out
probably people wouldn't expect this but
i'm gonna say mason that guy is like so
good at being hospitable and making sure
everybody's
having a good time we all went to joshua
tree and he was that was his idea
and like woke up in the morning and he's
like tied everything up who wouldn't
want to have a party with that guy
rachel hilson and michael cimino you
would probably fall on bb's camp where
you're
so invested in making sure we have a
good time the snacks are perfect
it'd be more of a dinner party over here
and michael would be more of a
michael that's a trap house that's a
stuff is breaking people's legs are
separated from the bodies i don't i
don't know i'm just gonna say though
michael cause he's a social butterfly so
i think he would throw a pretty cool
party
puerto ricans definitely throw the best
house parties just saying i throw little
soirees like every sunday
have little jam sessions i do know how
to throw a good party who's
most likely to learn a tick tock dance
and perform it flawlessly
bella and anthony kayvon bella
yeah bella and anthony yeah i mean they
do it in season two
of love victor so they do yep they've
they've
set an example bella would be the best
person to do
tick-tock dances anthony's really good
at like doing that but i think
bella definitely has to take the cake
here but give this one to bella she
knows that
whole tick tock thing better than any of
us i'm like the only one on tick tock
so i don't even need to hear it i'll
also save me who's most likely to become
a viral meme this season
you why me i mean i feel like felix has
plenty of funny things to say
you had amazing lines this season
between the two of us i think you would
become a viral man 100
maybe we'll become a viral meme together
we can will it to the universe
he's new to the show but raheem he's
played by anthony kayvon
i think he just has like a lot of funny
like facial expressions so probably him
i think this one's gotta go to anthony i
think there's so many viral moments with
that guy i think
even in the blooper reel he had some
moments that i'm surprised didn't go
viral
anthony would probably be the most
likely to become
a meme because he's just a meme in
general like a big walking meme
i think bibi will crown herself
on account of how good she is that one
line
in the trailer likes line of say the
word and i'll ditch these gays like a
corporation after pride month that is
really one of the greatest lines and
deliveries
that'll be a meme if it's not already
thank you buzzfeed we thank you for
choosing
air victor we know there are a lot of
other options for air travel out there
we appreciate you picking this one
be sure to watch love victor on hulu
check it out
you